i don't talk about al baldwin there we
go let's do it
so uh we love subtle transitions
i i well so i mean look we're talking
about trials we're talking about written
house we're talking about there's a
bunch of trials actually the armored
armory cases going on we have more
information on the alec baldwin uh case
a rust crew member this is the movie
rust is the name of the film where alec
baldwin shot and killed that woman he is
suing alec baldwin and the set armorer
for severe emotional distress over
shooting
the independent is reporting
fatal scene did not require baldwin to
pull trigger lawsuit claims
it's a claim of a lawsuit if somebody's
trying to make money so i don't know
that it's true a lot of people are
saying why would an electrician have you
know key details in that regard the
independent reports
a rust crew member who held the dying
helena hutchins in his arms has sued
alec baldwin armorer hannah gutierrez
reid and assistant director dave halls
for severe emotional distress over the
shooting head electrician sergey svetnoy
alleges in the lawsuit that the scene in
which miss hutchins was killed did not
call for mr baldwin to fire the weapon
which she had been told was cold mr
baldwin is sued in both his capacity as
an actor and a producer of the western
movie which has been shut down as
investigations into the death continues
mr savannoy claims in the court papers
that the bullet that killed mrs hutchins
also struck director joel souza almost
hit him as well according to tmz he
states that he is suing mr baldwin
because the star owed a duty to the
plaintiff and other crew members and
actors on the rust set to handle the
cult revolver provided to him by
defendant halls with reasonable care and
diligence for the safety of the rust
cast and crew
they're going to say quote this duty
called for defendant baldwin to double
check the cult revolver with halls upon
being handled to ensure did not contain
live ammunition court papers state the
lawsuit also claims the fatal scene did
not require baldwin to pull the gun's
trigger with the script instructing him
to draw the weapon and point it in the
general direction of the camera but
quote the scene did not call for the
defendant baldwin to shoot the cult
revolver
my understanding
is that the cult revolver especially a
piece from this era would be single
action not double action someone
commented on this yesterday which means
and actually i have a single action you
have to actually pull the hammer back
before it can be fired
the question then emerges
if we're assuming this lawsuit is
correct this election is the the
electrician's claims as a witness and
someone involved in the crew is right
maybe he's disgruntled maybe he was a
disgruntled crew member maybe he's lying
i don't know
the first question we have to ask is
why did alec baldwin
pull the hammer back on the gun
point it at an individual
why weren't there safety protocols in
place why did you pull the trigger
i think as i stated yesterday we didn't
do a full segment on this which is why i
wanted you know this story came out four
hours ago and i thought it was important
to bring up
we've been giving him the benefit out
the whole time for no reason
i'm not saying i know what happened i'm
saying the media has protected alec
baldwin and framed this whole story so
that from the get-go we assumed it was
an accident they first said it was a
blank they said it was a misfire which
is the wrong terminology they said
shrapnel hit the producer uh the
cinematographer killing her
we know all of that's not true now and
this is witness testimony granted this
guy's suing but it's still someone who
is on the crew who's making a statement
and saying this is what happened and
what was supposed to happen
in which case the facts we have to start
alec baldwin drew a gun
pulled the hammer back pointed it at the
cinematographer at the camera with a
cinematographer standing there fired the
gun with a live bullet in it
in order to assume that was an accident
we'd have to make a a ton of assumptions
he was mad he had motive
sounds like it right so no that's those
those are also more assumptions however
in the absence of evidence the the
solution that makes the least amount of
least amount of assumptions tends to be
the correct one not that we know
definitively not that we can say for
sure but i'm just pointing out it is
logically absurd to begin the the uh the
story as if we believe it was a mistake
well what's very clear is that alec
baldwin has a very skilled team of pr
people
that has been rolling this out bit by
bit manipulating the narrative seeding
things in our mind much the way a uh you
know interrogator will get you to say
yes and lead you places plant things out
there
uh very uh concerted effort which you
know even if it were an accident they
would do the same thing right if it was
brilliant the total accident he would
definitely hire a crisis management team
they would definitely be doing
everything that they're doing uh but to
the way that things are coming out bit
by bit by bit now
and when you really put it like that you
know he pulls back pulls back to action
points at the guy pull shoot
why so so here and doesn't he have a
history of like going off on people back
yeah
an attack remember he just attacked a
guy in new york over a parking space the
armor i think she was claiming that uh
she was afraid that people were afraid
of alec on set basically like if they
were like hey it's too dangerous you
can't do that that alec would flip his
lid and fire the person
he leaves some nasty voicemail for his
own daughter
calling her the worst names in the world
and being an absolute just he's trash
dude do you remember uh did you see the
video of him and his wife they got out
of the car they were getting chased by
like paparazzi they got out of the car
to talk to him it was like last week
there's video of it and he's like she
was my friend
and then he realized like i didn't say
it with enough emotion i got to repeat
myself she was my friend like he's such
an actor yeah most actors go crazy let
me look we got this music today alec
baldwin sue's man who accused actor of
punching him over a parking spot in new
york
he sues the guy so so so everyone
thought that tim was crazy when tim came
up with this idea that it's possible
this wasn't an accident right but
it's not even me coming up with an idea
it's me saying why are you making
assumptions this was an accident i know
we all know that alec baldwin is a huge
jerk and he always has been so there's
no reason to assume that this was an
accident there's no reason to assume
that there's right what what grace has
he built up what benefit of the doubt
has he built up he is he is the
equivalent of the n-word guy at the gas
station at this point dude from the
beginning everyone was like we have to
be nice to alec baldwin this must be
very hard for him i was like do you
think for one single second that if this
were to happen to someone for example
like james woods that he would be
compassionate and graceful he would be
on twitter before the body was cold
complaining about
gun laws he would be talking about he
went trick-or-treating afterwards and
was taking you know selfies and photos
of dressed up as a in a costume i pulled
up uh the video of the parking lot
incident and it shows alec he like
shoves the guy in the shoulder so he
says it disproves the claim
that you know he punched him this is
going back to 2018.
i think it's still it's still an
important point to make that alec
baldwin is a hot head yes like ian was
pointing out people were scared of him
on the set right people had complained
about what was going on and
i think we could even ignore all of that
and just take some basic facts
a woman died how did she die
she was shot we'll just we're gonna
we're gonna walk backwards she was shot
yeah how did she get shot an individual
fired a gun at her yeah the individual
was armed with what i believe was a
single action revolver likely 45 caliber
because it's a western
he pointed the gun at her pulled the
hammer back pulled the trigger
okay why did he do it
well according to one witness the scene
did not call for him to actually pull
the hammer back and pull the trigger but
he did anyway yeah so then why would he
have pulled the tr you know pull the
trigger well then we start getting into
the crew disputes the headedness of the
character
i don't understand why it's logical in
any capacity to say he accidentally
pulled a live firearm with a bullet
pulled the hammer back and shot a woman
and be like but let's figure out how
many how we can justify it as an
accident no you made a good point about
crisis management this dude's very
wealthy
very likely his pr firm immediately as
soon as it happened started saying we
need stories saying this they probably
seated false information it was a
misfire as a blank why to create the
narrative of an accident first and we
walked into that the first thing we said
was it was an accident then we learned
there was a live bullet we said wow how
did that happen that's a crazy accident
and then and then i stopped and talked
to him i thought to myself
so i have to assume a woman an armorer
who's trained with firearms accidentally
loaded a live round gave it to an
assistant director who didn't check it
but claimed it was cold gave it to alec
baldwin who wasn't supposed to pull the
trigger who then pulls the trigger and
all of that is true for me to continue
the accident narrative okay i dude i
don't like alec baldwin even though he's
just a tremendous actor which just
bothers me him and glenn clary glenn
ross is like one of the most powerful
scenes in film oh man
so good uh but the alternative and just
playing devil's advocate all you a-holes
out there they're gonna say that i'm
alex baldwin
they love you in the comments section by
the way no they hate me in the comment
section and there's like there's bots in
there running on me quiz quit reading
comments i love the comments
i love you guys you guys are incredible
i'm al the alternative is is what
that alec he came up with a way to
murder this woman no no no no no no
that's too many assumptions it's simple
hot headed alec baldwin shot a woman
that's it so i think someone put the
bullet in the gun sabotage that's that's
it's just an assumption but it's like
if i have to make one
it's going to be that they they've
they've made that action i don't have to
make one crew members have argued as
intentional sabotage and alec baldwin's
part however
if i'm going to make the least amount of
assumptions it's alec baldwin shot and
killed the woman well for sure that's
truth that's not even an assumption
right that's a valid
the hammer pointed the gun and pulled
the trigger motive is
this is a guy who's known to be a
hothead who who screamed at his own
daughter who shoved a guy over a parking
space
i'm i'm not trying to argue that he's a
rage-filled monster but that he has a
hot he has a temper
so if we're going to look at how this
woman died do i assume the armorer who's
trained in firearms accidentally loaded
a live bullet then gave it to a second
person who claimed to have checked it
but didn't who gave it to alec baldwin
who is trained for decades with firearms
who didn't check it or do i say there
was a producer dispute with the crew
over the conditions on the set
and then the guy who's running one of
the producers
shoots a woman
why would we so there's a lot of things
that are very difficult to believe in
each of these scenarios they're all
incredible like wow how how are any
they're doing live target practice on
the set they're probably getting a
hammer the night before coming in all
wasted
this this girl doesn't even know she's
doing the armor
but why would you assume that she said
she's 24 she was like i'm not
comfortable in this job i'm doing two
she's doing two jobs at once on the set
but it's like you can't say it to alec
because he'll fire you on the spot i
think it's crazy to be to assume that
the one person who was not
treating the gun properly was the one
person whose job it is to treat the gun
properly you know what i mean right the
armorer is the expert on set why would i
assume she made the mistake and kill and
resulted in a person dying instead of
alec baldwin who pulled the trigger so
you think you think that she handed over
a gun that had a blank in it and alec
baldwin inserted a live round in between
receiving the handgun and discharging it
if we're going to start with all of the
facts laid in front of us
it is i in my opinion slightly more
probable that alec baldwin loaded the
gun no shot than than some gruntled crew
member that walked off
so the crew member is there a chain of
of of possession the armorer hannah
gutierrez do they have to sign for it
and stuff i don't know yeah
right so
i'm not saying it's a it's it's likely
i'm not saying it's true i'm just saying
why would i assume
the armorer made a mistake the assistant
director failed to check it and then
alec baldwin for no reason
pulled the trigger at a woman and then
add to it very clearly a skilled pr team
is seeding stories manipulating the
media getting you don't know that for
sure it's a big assumption i think it's
likely and fair to say my point is i
don't know it's so objective it's
annoying sometimes i don't know what
happened i'm just saying that looking at
like a mathematical equation
you have this massive tree of like an of
an algorithm like a flow chart of all of
the things that had to happen for this
insane accident to occur and then over
here you have
angry crew
alec baldwin hot head shot a woman like
it's three steps it's a guy said i'm
angry with the crew and then shot a
woman versus accident accident accident
sabotage conspiracy angry crew and i
just right and we're falling into the
trap of trying to apply rational
thinking to irrational people doing
irrational things and hot-headed people
who have a temper who act out sometimes
now we still don't know it i think we
have to wait until the police
investigation comes out uh if they're
going to even investigate it properly if
a lot of the investigation wasn't
compromised by a lot of his money the
d.a said that they know who put the
bullet in the gun oh wow so maybe
look yeah we'll see i'm just saying
i feel like a crisis management team
likely was involved in seeding stories
that were clearly false
to create the accident narrative first
and then prejudice individuals who read
on but now you have a guy who has in a
sworn statement a deposition lawsuit in
his deposition in a lawsuit saying the
scene did not call for him to fire the
gun that is that's big that is big
that's huge as soon as i saw that i was
like this changes a lot and there's a
little bit of motive yeah right there
was disputes there was kind of contested
and people were quitting they were
walking off set yeah so imagine you've
got hot head alec baldwin trying to run
a movie where
he's a hothead people like you know ian
mentioned people were scared they would
get fired hannah gutierrez i guess had
said that is that what you were saying
uh that's what i interpreted from the
article i was reading but remember too
remember we were talking about this
before the show it is known in the actor
community that even a blank can kill
somebody what yeah that was the cat oh
the cat is going to get in here up the
stairs
it's known in the actor community and
alec was an actor then a young actor put
a blank to his head and killed himself
by accident thinking it was a blank and
then it wasn't going to kill him so it's
known in hollywood that blanks can be
lethal that's john eric hexham hexam and
and again alec baldwin has decades of
action movie experience right there was
already a witness who testified that
they work with alec baldwin and he knows
not only standard gun protocol safety
but onset gun safety and he violated so
alec baldwin
for this accident to have occurred
slipped his mind standard gun safety
slipped his mind standard protocol
pulled the trigger on a gun that in a
scene that didn't call for it was handed
a gun by a guy who claimed to attack it
but didn't by a woman who accidentally
put a live bullet in it and didn't check
that's insane to assume they were
apparently doing live target practice on
down time on set and then they're like
no no every people are denying that they
were doing it at all but they're like
dude there's live ammo all over the set
they were going out and shooting at cans
between takes
yeesh
i don't know we'll see i have a feeling
nothing bad is going to happen to dude i
wonder
if the shooter's
the production team has got to get
charged the armor and the assistant
director all need to be charged in this
i was reading legal analysis over basic
questions and it seems like based on the
facts we have that have been released
whatever the claims are involuntary
manslaughter is
set
the fact that it is standard safety
protocol not to point a weapon at
someone to pull the trigger the fact
that he didn't check when he had the
opportunity to do so means someone died
at his hand it was an accident but he's
responsible involuntary manslaughter
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
p.m and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you